democratic senator jackie rosen is  touting the american rescue plan by  visiting a locally owned small business  the senator met with the staff at the  truffles and bacon near eastern and  pebble  the owner says access to federal relief  and those ppp loans really helped keep  her business afloat we asked senator  rosen what she says her colleagues who  voted against the measure  when it helped bring back jobs to the  valley  that's everything that's everything and  so  i looked at the american rescue plan and  the covert relief as investing  in ourselves and our friends our  neighbors and communities so that's what  i tell my colleagues  last year the senator's office was able  to help more than a thousand  local small businesses the senator says  99 percent of businesses in nevada are  considered small business